the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now
or next our media group you know i hear
that they're standing in line for hours
tonight on politics now new rules and
long lines
businesses that can start allowing more
people in while health officials trying
to get the vaccine out quickly
plus these dollars
thankfully are a little bit flexible
with how we can utilize them
money for schools renters and small
businesses the state's economic stimulus
being pushed through the legislative
session
you identify as queer i identify as
bisexual
and sexual and we meet one of the newest
members of the hispanic legislative
caucus
assemblywoman cecilia gonzalez
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler signs of progress in the
fight against the coronavirus
hope for some relief to businesses that
are struggling to get through these
health guidelines
starting on monday some of nevada's
restrictions will be eased
governor steve sisselak laid out a
75-day plan to fully reopen the economy
starting on monday indoor dining places
of worship gyms and gaming floors at
casinos
bowling alleys as well they will move to
a limit of 100 people
or 35 capacity on thursday the governor
also gave a vaccine update
and he says more than 390 000 doses have
been administered
however there is concern it's not
happening fast enough
you may have seen how we're experiencing
long lines at vaccination sites
the clark county convention center is an
example today with seniors
70 and up standing for hours
with all due respect to the hard work
going into this and while i know you
don't
run the southern nevada health district
is it time for the state to team up to
try to help fix
technical issues to perhaps do
drive-through vaccination sites
they're doing those drive-throughs in
california
well we have uh my team has been in
southern nevada they're working with
southern nevada to help alleviate
these situations we're taking federal
advice as it becomes available on this
we certainly don't want our seniors our
most vulnerable standing in line for
hours
you know i hear that they're standing in
line for hours and then the health
district is telling me that
you know 15 of the people aren't showing
up for appointments and there's
duplicate appointments
this is a enormous a herculean task to
undertake
the governor also expressed support for
getting children back in schools and he
pointed out
16 of nevada's 17 counties have already
taken that step
however as we know most of the clark
county school district is still doing
distance learning at least
until early march now to look at the
state legislative session
a hot topic in the session so far fixing
nevada's unemployment system
lawmakers started talking about this
issue in senate bill 75
a bill that was requested by dieter
testimony from the department included
the technical changes among staff
how much money employers are paying into
the system and borrowing money from the
federal government
however the focus of the event quickly
turned to
why it's taking so long for nevadans to
get their money
dieter blames it on a tsunami of fraud
and in order to confirm fraud dieter
says
it needs to identify each claim and
that's just taking up resources
this head-on fraud has really
um slowed down the entire process
of being able to get these people paid
we want to get them paid trust me
but um we also don't want to send bad
money out the door
dieter says it's recovered a hundred
million dollars in fraudulent payments
already
and prevented two billion dollars from
being sent to fake accounts
no vote was taken on that senate bill
some criminal justice and police reform
bills are also starting to be written up
in carson city
lawmakers promised to take measures to
deal with bias training after a summer
of black lives matter protests
senate bill 108 would require any person
employed in the criminal justice system
to take implicit
bias and cultural competency training
it's sponsored by the senate judiciary
committee
a bill requiring police officers to
complete those trainings already took
effect back in 2019
this bill would apply to other people in
law enforcement mainly
the courts and attorneys it does not
have a hearing schedule just yet
democrats are making another run at
passing a dignity in
death bill it's the fourth straight
session a physician assisted suicide
bill has been
introduced the 2019 version passed the
senate but not the assembly
this version is sponsored by state
senator dallas harris
in this case a secondary physician and
two witnesses would have to sign off on
administering the lethal drugs
oregon was the first state to pass a
dignity and death measure about 20 years
ago
so far there about a thousand people
have taken advantage
more than 90 percent of them were in
hospice care at the time
another big topic is economic assistance
more than half a billion dollars in
federal money is being set aside for
renters and schools here in southern
nevada
the spending was approved by the interim
finance committee this week
in all 208 million dollars is going to
rental assistance programs
nevada's division of housing estimates
it'll help about 20 thousand households
162 million dollars will be sent spent
here in clark county money will go
directly from the state's account
right to the landlord the clark county
school district is getting a larger
chunk of money as well about 350 million
dollars
but it's important to note this will be
on top of money that's already in the
distributive school account
the money is slated to help reopen
schools safely and outfit them with new
technology state senate majority leader
nicole cannizzaro told 8 news now some
ways the money could be spent is to fund
some alert summer learning teacher
training and sanitation
one of the things that some of these
funds can be utilized for for example
are things like addressing learning loss
with students so how do we start to do
that
with providing assistance for summer pro
for summer learning programs
with training for our educators on how
to
keep the classroom safe and sanitized to
protect against
the virus once we start to open up
schools there's money in there to
address
kids who might be either in an english
language learner
program or in a lower income community
and so have had harder access
harder a more difficult time accessing
our educational facilities during the
pandemic when they haven't been able to
attend in school and so
there's some guidance in there that
allows for us
to help with those programs to address
some of the needs of those students
these dollars thankfully are a little
bit flexible
with how we can utilize them so to put
this in perspective the entire general
fund for the state budget a year
is about 4 billion dollars the 630
million dollar federal stimulus approved
a month and a half ago
it's a hefty chunk of change we're going
to have a link to apply for the rental
assistance and the other information
about this
at eight newsnow dot com the first bill
to pass and be signed by governor
sisilak was money for small businesses
assembly bill 106 was fast tracked
through this week
it puts 50 million more dollars into a
pandemic grant program called pets
orcomanna explains who could get that
funding
[Applause]
we took a hit by having to reduce staff
in some areas
like many nevada small businesses sonia
pedowick's consulting company has been
crippled by coven 19.
she applied for the pandemic emergency
technical support or pets grant last
fall to get help
i met all of the qualifications as
outlined in the portal
but with so many asking for aid the
money just wasn't there
now there's hope i'd love to put it back
into workforce right and be able to hire
back staff and talent
offset some of my overhead costs would
be you know a blessing for many of our
small businesses
the funding they were provided was a
difference between staying open or
closing their doors
the same goes for non-profits such as
united citizens foundation which
provides mental health services to kids
and families
staff say the money made a difference so
the pets grant allowed us to fill in
fill in that gap
to be able to see some kids that did not
have a pay source that did not have
insurance
those in limbo right now can only do one
thing i'm
waiting and being as patient as i can
orkomana
8 news now because the state gives this
out it's accessible to small businesses
with less than 50 employees
many of those companies couldn't get the
ppp loans before to stay afloat
corporations though cannot apply for it
the state says all funds have to be
distributed by june 30th
there are a couple of bills up in the
legislative session that deal with pets
and
animal issues senate bill 103 for
example would stop your home insurance
company from raising or canceling your
insurance based on the breed of your dog
many companies charge higher insurance
if you have a dog like a pit bull or a
rottweiler
assembly bill 101 allows veterans to
give cbd or cannabis products to their
animals for medical treatments
neither of those bills have had their
first hearing schedule just yet
next on politics now criminal justice
reform in the legislature
how do we provide services to folks to
really address why they're offending in
the first place
welcome back to politics now
there are several new first-time
lawmakers up at the state legislature in
carson city
including some of the youngest members
of the legislature ever
three freshman democrats are joining the
hispanic legislative caucus
and christian cazares has been talking
to them christian hello that's right
john well this week i talked to
assemblywoman cecilia gonzalez she
represents district 16
which is in the central portion of clark
county she is half
thai and half mexican i asked her about
representing her heritage
and criminal justice reform you're kind
of like a part of this new wave of
latinos and also a
younger generation that's going uh into
into the leadership role um what's that
like
and also how do you think that'll kind
of play a part in
in working down the road and kind of you
know working also
to get support from both sides of the
aisle
yeah great question thank you so much
you know it is such a privilege and an
honor
um to join my latina and latino brothers
and sisters up here
i think that um you know
it matters you know on the campaign
trail i can't tell you how many
um text messages i have you know
screenshoted and saved where folks are
like you know
you're mexican i'm mexican you have
three mexican votes in this household
representation really matters and it it
matters in a way where folks can look
at their elected officials and their
leaders and think to themselves you know
that's a latina
or that's an asian american woman you
know
i can see myself in that person i can
see myself in in their story
and that i can also become an elected
official as well and that i deserve to
be a leader to represent our community
i was reading a little bit about you and
i i saw that obviously you have a big
passion for the criminal justice
system reform what comes next in your
mind
and you know how much change do you
think that you
can accomplish during your time yeah
that's a great question i think that
criminal justice reform
um as you've seen in the last couple
years has
really gained a lot of bipartisanship
you know our
our communities are hurting um our
families are hurting
our prison system you know is hurting in
terms of
not being funded to what they need to be
right and so
unfortunately here in nevada we
incarcerate higher than the national
average and so
i'm really looking forward to working on
bringing
change on how we view offenders we could
see
some sort of bill being introduced by
you hopefully soon
yes i did submit a bdr to address the
prison population in a national health
pandemic i'm very excited
to work on that with a lot of different
community partners and stakeholders i'm
currently in that process
is it safe to say that you know that you
are like an lgbt
ally and if so you know being nevada
being so liberal and
so far um you know they've they've made
so many steps
moving forward and in in that area
is that something that maybe you see
yourself kind of spearheading some sort
of uh
you know action or something down the
road yeah so um
great question i love the question um i
actually do identify as queer i identify
as bisexual
pansexual and so um not only am i an
ally but i am
a member of the community and i'm the
first asian um
american lgbtq queer elected
official in this state um so that's a
lot right
and so um i definitely am looking
forward to
um you know with sessions to come and
time to come continue that work of
advocacy for the
the community very interesting christian
uh did assemblywoman gonzalez give any
other
insight on some other measures that
she's working on up in carson city
actually yes she said that she's also
working on a bill to make lower income
people
a protected class another related
climate change
uh bills that's that's all i have for
you right now john back to you in this
right prince thank you chris appreciate
that
you're watching politics now
you've probably heard about house arrest
before or bail or
bond alternatives to being in jail while
someone is awaiting trial
but accused murderers turns out they're
not always in custody
the i-team's vanessa murphy takes a
closer look at this issue
[Music]
at least 35 defendants charged with
murder in clark county are not in jail
the circumstances vary a woman who
police say shoved an elderly man
off a bus a security guard accused of
killing a man on the job
and several alleged acts of domestic
violence
at least nine are accused of killing
children
most of them their own he paid less
for his bond than the cost of my child's
funeral
veronica melton's son giovanni was 14
years old
her ex-husband wendell melton is accused
of shooting him back in 2017
because he was gay today he's on house
arrest awaiting trial
utterly perplexing i don't understand
the system
metro deputy chief laz chavez says on
average
30 to 40 people charged with murder are
not behind bars
that's about 10 percent of open murder
cases right now
it's frustrating it's frustrating for
the police department metro police keep
track of electronic monitoring
and house arrest some of the worst
crimes which is the taking
the life of another human being is that
the one where you get to go home
or not i would argue that it's not
you're innocent
until proven guilty azi fumo is a
criminal defense attorney
just because the accusation is made that
someone has committed a crime doesn't
mean they're guilty of that crime
there's a process for it the burden
falls on prosecutors to convince a judge
to keep the person in jail
99 of these cases the district
attorney's office
seeks a significant bail district
attorney steve wolfson says that may be
as much as a million dollars in some
cases
it's always up to the judge the judges
make the ultimate decision the judge
considers whether the defendant will be
a danger to the community
according to metro from 2018 to 2020
eight defendants charged with murder who
were on house arrest were accused of
committing new crimes including assault
sex offense and more the judge also
considers whether a defendant will
willingly return to court
the department reports no defendants
charged with murder fled over the past
two years
but in 2019 christopher prestopino was a
no-show
he's accused of killing a woman and
dumping her body in the desert
he posted a 500-thousand dollar bond
police found him at his house while he
was supposed to be in court
and took him back to jail it took the
wind out of the sales of
all of us thinking that this is the one
who meets the criteria for house arrest
the i-team examined court records to
find out whether
certain judges were more likely to grant
bail house arrest or electronic
monitoring
for defendants charged with murder and
we found
no major trends i think now we're
finally
equaling the scales of justice because
we have judges who understand the law we
will continue to
investigate these crimes what happens
afterwards
needs to be in my opinion needs to be
looked at and maybe reconsidered
wolfson says a defendant out of custody
can sometimes delay a case
if a defendant isn't in jail he says
their legal team may not hesitate in
asking for continuances
veronica melton says she's been waiting
more than three years
for justice but the action and the
result is still the same
i still have a dead child vanessa murphy
8 news now
in one case our i-team found bail was
reduced for the defendant because of the
coronavirus
according to court records though he has
asthma metro police say as of thursday
15
inmates have kova 19 and were in
isolation deputy chief chavez who you
heard from there
insists there is room for defendants
charged with murder to be safely housed
metro reports 36 vacancy
the second impeachment trial meanwhile
of donald trump is underway in
washington d.c
house managers have argued the capital
attack cost taxpayers millions of
dollars but more importantly
has compromised american national
security washington d.c correspondent
alexander limon reports good evening and
once again today the house impeachment
managers played videos
including some of their fellow lawmakers
remembering how they used pieces of
furniture inside the u.s capitol
to make makeshift weapons in case they
needed to fight their way
out of the mob one of the impeachment
managers congresswoman diana degette
argued the mob came because former
president donald trump
invited them their own statements before
during and after the attack made clear
the attack was done
for donald trump at his instructions
and to fulfill his wishes
lead impeachment manager congressman
jamie raskin said trump knew
his supporters could become violent
because it happened before
when extremists plotted to kidnap
michigan's governor
when responding to extremist plots in
michigan trump showed he knew how to use
the power of a mob
to advance his political objectives but
despite the case house managers are
trying to make
most republican senators say the
managers haven't proved
trump caused the attack particularly
remembering
the defense has not yet brought its case
where i'm sure they're going to show
footage of the president's actual speech
where he said go and peacefully
protest raskin told senators there's no
reason to believe trump
won't continue to promote violence if he
ever returns to office
would you bet the lives of more police
officers on that
would you bet the safety of your family
on that
would you bet the future of your
democracy on that
a conviction by the u.s senate would
block trump from running for office
again in the future
starting tomorrow we'll hear the defense
from trump's lawyers
reporting in washington alexandra limon
of course that was earlier in the week
the u.s attorney for nevada is one of
dozens that will be leaving his post
nicholas tretanich announced his last
day will be february 28th
drewtanich was sworn in in january 2019
after unanimous confirmation by the u.s
senate before that
he served as chief of staff to nevada's
attorney general at the time
adam laxalt